[Music]  I designed Megan to protect Katie from  feeling lonely  she will recognize you as her primary  user and when you do that you're going  to pair with her  crazy it's insane right oh don't I look  nice  Megan your goal is to protect Katie from  harm both physical and emotional  [Music]  I won't let anything harm you I love her  like it's not a person Katie you don't  get to say that  [Music]  you will be my love very good  what are you doing couldn't sleep  occupational hazard  but your full attention  don't stop  what the hell is that  [Music]  you should probably run  Megan have I done something to upset you  Gemma I know you think you're maximizing  your objective function oh really  [Music]  well  [Music]  you'd have to shut her down Jesus Christ  [Music]  I have a new primary user now me  thank you  did you make him do something bad  what's going on  [Music]  what are you I'm Megan  baby  [Music]  foreign  [Music]